hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast as
morality testing
providing unique process control for
downstream operations
presented by dr alaise jungbauer and dr
christine wright
i am michelle ashton of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinth and
sponsored by
advanced instruments for more
information
on our sponsor please visit
aicompanies.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr alice winbauer
osmolality testing providing unique
process control
for downstream operations and dr
christine wright
application scientist at advanced
instruments
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr gingbauer
and dr wright you may now begin
your presentation
thank you so much for that introduction
my name
is christina wright and today i will be
talking a little bit
about obsolete testing um and will be
joined
as is mentioned by dr alice youngbauer
of the boku to talk about
how this test really provides unique
process control
for downstream operations
just to give you a little bit of insight
into what we'll be discussing today
we do want to start at the beginning
really talk about what osmolality is
as a test how it applies to bio
processing where it really fits in
within a bioprocessing workflow and then
we'll get into the good stuff we'll get
into some new data
that dr youngbauer would like to present
kind of go over a study that he oversaw
and discuss some
key takeaways then we'll wrap up by
discussing how advanced instruments has
really provided the devices and the
technology that's necessary
to implement osmolality testing no
matter where you are in your workflow
but particularly for downstream
processing
so let's go ahead and get started if we
want to start by just
defining osmolality it's a colligative
property
of any liquid solution so anytime a
solute is introduced into a solvent
the resulting solution is going to
differ from that initial solvent in
several ways
and osmolality is one key measurement to
really pick up on those differences
it's a concentration measurement it's
the total number of solutes
in a liquid solution typically expressed
in
milliosmoles of the solute
per kilogram of the solvent and that's
important we'll get a little bit more
into
why that measure of mass of the solvent
is so important in a second
because obviously is not dependent on
volume
but on and on the mass of the solvent
it's not necessarily affected
by a change in the solution's
temperature
so you could see you could start to see
why this may play an important role when
it comes to bioprocessing where
temperature
pressure different parameters are
changing
one question i know that i get a lot
when we talk about osmolality testing is
what exactly is the difference between
osmolarity
with an r and osmolality which is what
we're talking about today
so i wanted to dive a little bit deeper
into this
and give some really clear insight into
what the differences are so
i mentioned that osmolality is a
concentration expresses osmoles of
solute per kilogram of solvent
this is different than when we talk
about osmolarity
which is actually osmoles of solute per
liter
of the total solution and you can see in
that second point
while osmolarity is actually dependent
on temperature and pressure of the
solvent
because volume itself is temperature
dependent
osmolality is not something that's
dependent on the temperature
and the pressure of the solvent that
you're looking at so what we tend to see
is that osmolality is actually a
preferred concentration measurement
within biological systems and
this is something that really plays a
role into the study that dr youngbauer
will be discussing later so i
kind of like to bring bring you in right
now dr young bauer
and ask what where is this temperature
independence when we talk about
osmolality testing
where is that most relevant in your
experience
i think it is extremely relevant when
you prepare
buffers mainly buffers with
stocks through a stock solution in a
high
solute concentration and
there are a couple of unit operations
in bioprocessing or downstream
processing which are really sensitive to
temperature one
example for instance is hydrophobic
intex chromatography
or reversed phase chromatography so
these two unit operations
are extremely important at
extremely dependent on temperature yeah
so the
retention time or the yield would
highly depend on the temperature so
when you actually for instance prepare a
buffer
at 4 degrees and then use the buffer at
room temperature
ph and conductivity will change
osmolality does not
i think this is one of the prime
examples
perfect okay and that's a really great
point so
i think it sets us up really nicely to
get into
more of the study that you were able to
do and recently published on
so we'll get into more of that data in a
bit
one thing that i did want to kind of go
through
um because obviously we're today we want
to focus on purification
um but we also wanted to work through
and kind of discuss some of the
applications for osmolality testing in
other areas of bioprocessing
and of course feel free to reach out we
do have
materials and extra resources available
that kind of
speak to some of these applications as
well
so if we start with more upstream uh
monoclonal antibody processing
let's just take kind of an overview of
where osmolality testing would fit into
cell line development
so really when when we want to ensure
that cell media and culture conditions
are
are optimized so that clonal screening
and selection
and characterization can be done
efficiently and effectively
observability testing is a really great
parameter
to put into place at this time um
setting a range for osmolality
really sets you up for productive and
stable cell lines so that you can get
further processing done
more efficiently with media preparation
and quality control around media
preparation
it's important to check the osmolality
of any raw materials that could be going
into the media
and then the final media composition or
concentration itself should definitely
be measured using auxiliary testing
just to make sure that the cultures
are really able to thrive you want to
have that optimal cell viability and
ultimately
yield so osmolality is definitely a
parameter here
that should be maintained and checked
and during the process of cell culture
monitoring whether you're working
with shake flasks or bags or bioreactors
osmolality is something that should
definitely be monitored and considered
a critical parameter as this process is
ongoing
to ensure that all the conditions are
really optimized for ideal growth
for ideal health if there are other
parameters that
you know you need to keep in check this
is a great way
a very robust measurement to make sure
that that's happening as far as
the media and the concentration of the
media is concerned
so we spoke to you a little bit about
downstream processing
um alloy spoke to some of the
applications with buffer preparation
uh again similar to with media
preparation making sure that you know
exactly what's going on this is a really
credible and robust measurement to make
sure that you understand the composition
and concentration of your buffers
as you work through the key operations
whether it's chromatography or
for filtration today we'll be focusing
more on the purification the
chromatography steps
so again this is where we'll speak a
little bit more to
how osmolality testing can be used to
predict protein quantity
and potentially identify any process
deviations but there's also certainly
an application within a buffer exchange
or really any filtration operation but
when we talk about buffer exchange and
making sure that you can
um if you already have a set number of
exchanges or dia volumes
tracking that concentration as you're
going through
your exchanges or maybe even optimizing
and reducing the number of exchanges
used
and when it comes to the uh
buffer preparation and qc and just
speaking to these
these buffers that are used throughout
downstream processing it's critical
um as dr young bauer mentioned so we did
want to show
some data from a study that we completed
last year
and while simple it really does show
some pretty
key information when it comes to
dilution
curves and as the concentration
of of key buffers and buffer components
change you tend to see while maybe not
perfectly
linear you tend to see more of a
traceable
predictable pattern with osmolality over
those concentrations that really take up
the full um the full
span and possible range of osmolality
testing
if we compare that to something like
conductivity certainly we're not seeing
a linear curve but
another issue is that for example with
something that's weakly dissociating
like acetic acid here
you tend to see that at really high
concentrations there's not that
resolution
there isn't a great distance between
the conductivity of this uh
this acetic acid at let's say
a concentration of one molar versus a
concentration of two molar
and while we know that um that teams are
not necessarily working at these higher
concentrations
throughout the downstream process we
also are seeing a trend
in inline dilution systems for example
so if you start with these high
concentrated stocks
um then then you will have to kind of
consider what the concentrations of
those starting materials are so that's
why we wanted to take in a full range of
the concentration of these buffers
and last but not least if we talk about
formulation
and the role of osmo osmolality testing
in formulation and
final product testing for formulation
development certainly screening
potential formulation concentrations
with osmolality
could be key especially when you have a
lot of different conditions and
formulations that are being tested
we certainly offer ways that you could
do this more high throughput
and multiple tests in a run
when it comes to final formulations and
verifying concentrations of excipients
this can also be achieved with
optimality testing
additionally osmolality has been
associated
with the injection site pain
experience with some of the final
formulations in the final products
of maps and lastly
um oscillating is actually a compendial
test
so it's something that we pretty much
see a hundred percent use for that
that last identity measurement
um and specification so of course this
is an area where we see a lot of value
for this test
so that's just a little bit of an
overview at each of these areas of
course we
are more than happy to provide
additional information but we at least
wanted to present
the general idea of where we fit when it
comes to upstream
downstream formulation and final product
so now we will actually get into
the exciting data that dr young bauer
recently published and kind of speak to
more of a novel area really of
osmolality testing when it comes to
um being a predictor of protein
concentration during chromatography
operations
so dr youngbauer if you want to take
over
thank you christina for uh this
introduction to osmolality
and actually explaining the difference
between
osmolarity and osmolality actually there
is a
quite a big confusion in the scientific
community about these terms or
maybe for a lot of people whose morality
actually is a new german they have not
heard before
the work we have actually done in
this context is done within a bigger
frame
we are interested in real-time release
and this is actually the testing
of our process and in process
data to actually know the quality
of the product at any stage in the
process
and then after you have finished the
process
you are no you are aware or you are
you know that your product is within
specification and therefore we measure a
combination of material
attributes and process controls and
actually
there is a guideline for a couple of
years
already available from fda and
international uh actually committee of
harmonization
the ich q8 guideline on real-time
release
we should be aware that real-time
release actually helps us to improve
product quality
the consistency but also adds on
a lot of economics because we assume or
it is assumed
that with real-time really these batch
failures can be
substantially cut down
the bottleneck for the real-time control
and real-time release is
actually often uh the product
specific inline sensors or
fast online monitors and
actually these fast online
methods can be replaced by statistical
models but this is also known under
soft sensors so
actually i will explain you in a couple
of minutes yeah
about real-time monitoring and uh
statistical modeling of downstream
on the right-hand side you see the
reference where we have published
statist data and you find
more actually information and also the
references
i think i advise you you could also
check our
annual report of the institute of
bioprocess science and engineering
where you will also get more
information so what you do actually
you connect your chromatography
workstation to different sensors
yeah and do uh online and headline
measurements so you would have
offline signals and online signals
and then with this online and offline
signals you do a statistical model
that means the offline signals
are used actually to predict the offline
the online signals and then you get
an idea of your process stream
in real time so what we have shown in
this publication
that we are able to predict host cell
protein
dna hostile dna and some
product quality in real time
so now actually together with the
company advanced instruments we wanted
to explore
uh a bit the
actually the effect
of osmolality as a predictor
for our real-time monitoring
and statistical modeling
so um and also we did a
flows through chromatography like a
polishing step to remove
aggregates from monomers
in an antibody process uh below you find
the paper uh which we have published
recently and
there you find all the details uh i just
want to
explain you one actually simple
statistical term this is the rmse
this is the relative mean square error
this is actually the sum of
all errors between
the measured and the predicted values
yeah so when we assume that we take
osmolality uh into
account then we see that with osmolality
actually we get a lower
or this rsme
a lower prediction error compared to
uv 280 to 60 to 14 ph
and conductivity so
if you look the experiments i don't want
to go do
all the experiments we have done yeah uh
on the uh lower right corner
of course osmolality alone
would not be able to predict actually
this product quantity but uv
280 to 60 and osmolality
have actually a substantial lower uh
prediction error and this was also
puzzling us
when we wrote up uh the the manuscript
because you need an explanation
why uh actually is the osmolality
uh alone better than ph
uh uh and uh conductivity
together with the spectroscopic methods
i think one reason is actually what we
capture with the osmolarity is
actually the number of
solutes and what we also
uh have mentioned in in the paper
is actually the osmolality itself
yeah uh captures uh
uh much faster actually all the
transition
in the composition uh of
the process fluid so
uh you see here i already mentioned
we published this uh this year in the
showing of chemical technology
and biotechnology uh and actually
if you want to get more information
i advise you to read this paper
so that for us was really
actually a surprise that osmolarity
is a really a good predictor
also we should have loaded in advance
because the osmolality
itself yeah is uh highly
uh dependent actually on the
change of solution um
you know the buffer itself yeah uh
changes uh actually with the the buffer
ph
changes with uh dilution yeah
uh the the conductivity
uh uh concentration relationship
is not fully linear this has been
already elaborated by christina
and i think if we go back to our basic
chemistry we should
consider australia's dilution law
and therefore including osmolality
because we know that the dissociation
of a constant of a weak
acid or base actually is highly
dependent
on the concentration
so now we have to ask
ourselves how could it is also
translated
into new actually
areas in bioprocessing in
cell and gene therapy because it is well
known uh
in the field of formulation that the
osmotic pressure has a
high influence on the viability
of the cells on the right hand side
you see this prime example
the red blood cells in the middle you
see
how happy the red blood cells are they
look like donuts
in isotonic solution
actually in a hypertonic solution
actually they start to actually
increase in volume until they would
burst
in hypotonic solution they shrink yeah
and actually get the kind of
blurred so therefore it is really
important
in this field to keep our bioprocessing
solutions also during
downstream processing cells are
happy in isotonic conditions
so that means when we prepare
buffers loading buffers wash buffers
uh illusion buffers uh
actually it's really important uh
to actually check our
osmolality because this would it will
increase yield
improve the quality of cells or viruses
yeah
and in case of stem cells it knows is
known that
it would remove biophysical stress from
steroids
from cells which could lead to an
uh apparent uh dissociation
so this was a
kind of outlook into
the future we are also what was morality
would be very
important and now i want to actually
hand over again
to christina
thank you so much dr young bauer and um
i definitely
appreciate you speaking to kind of how
this would also apply and translate
to the cell and gene therapy space i
know that that's a question that we've
gotten before
and it's certainly an area of interest
for a lot of people
in in our field so we look forward to
kind of
working our way into that space and
hopefully getting some really valuable
insight from you and your team even when
it comes to
the cell and gene therapy space as well
in osmolality testing
thank you so much for that report uh
we're certainly
very excited about the data and um
kind of the story that comes from that
and also to see
you know where it leads us like i said
whether it's into cell and gene therapy
or advancements with purification
processing
so one thing that i did want to
provide is we've talked a lot about
osmolality
testing but the question is how do we
accomplish this
and what is advanced instruments doing
to make sure that this is something that
is accurate it's a test that's robust
and really as far as
what services and what offers we can
provide we want to make it something
that's really easy
for our customers to obtain and then to
use
so just to give you an idea of what
types of
instruments we have available i did want
to show we have a single sample
microosmometer as well as a
multi-sample microatmometer they're now
available
that would be the osmotec and the
osmotec pro respectively
um so the major difference here is with
the osmotec pro
you can run up to 20 samples in one
sitting
that will kind of automatically run
around that carousel
as opposed to running one at a time so
really it has more to do with the
throughput and however
the number of samples that you need to
run in one
sitting or in one day and we can
certainly
help you figure out what the best
instrument is for you
however they both offer really a lot of
great features
and benefits for those in biopharma and
biotech
as you can see there's a lot of those
features listed here the accuracy
and precision that advanced instruments
has really become known for
of course that's something that we've
carried through to this osmotec
portfolio
um really great settings and permissions
that
provide flexibility so we recognize that
there are customers that
really have to focus in on things like
21 cfr part 11
and that data compliance and that data
security
whatever you need when it comes to that
we have with these instruments
however if you're at the other end of
the spectrum you don't need that right
now or it's not something that you need
maybe fully installed there is that
flexibility to
to work within different parameters and
that's really just up to the user
for each of these instruments also as
far as testing time
um while this would be an outline
measurement
for those of you that are in
purification it's a 90 second test time
for each test for each sample run so
it's relatively fast
um and but still providing you that
accuracy and precision that you need
so the other thing that's really unique
about our instruments um
is the data management and you can see
here that we have
several ways now that you can get data
very quickly
from the instrument into your system
into your
database whatever it is whatever kind of
electronic records you have
or systems that you use from opc
to an embedded web server where you can
view the data remotely
we have the lis and the lims connections
available
as well as the ability to push
the data from the instrument into your
network
pretty seamlessly you can do that
automatically you can set it up to do it
at a pretty regular cadence or it's
something that you can
do manually whenever you need it so you
can see all those different ways they're
listed here
um and again just allowing flexibility
so
if it's something where you're looking
to upgrade to a better
level of connectivity you can if you're
already printing out results and you
want to keep it that way for now but you
want the option to
kind of move ahead in the future
we do offer that with the osmotec line
of osmometers
and the service and support i mentioned
this but just wanted to bring your
attention to this as well because
it's not always just about the
instrument but also making sure that the
installation is there we offer training
validation services are also
provided along with each of these
instruments if that's something that you
wish to have
preventative maintenance maintenance and
of course the technical support that you
would need
to make sure that if you do run into any
issues with your instrument they can be
resolved quickly
and thoroughly
so really just to kind of wrap up
everything
that we've discussed today ozility
testing
is definitely a valuable orthogonal tool
um as far as measuring buffer
concentration within downstream workflow
so
this means more than just that buffer qc
measurement
and as dr young bauer explains
because it's independent of temperature
it's something that really
becomes a valuable tool within
bioprocessing and when we speak to
purification in particular
you're measuring um those those buffers
throughout this process it's an
in-process test not necessarily just to
check it and leave it
type of test so the new publication
specifically and again
we are happy to point you in the
direction of the paper from dr
youngbauer's team
um if you'd like more information on
that but it shows that osmolality can
serve as an in-process indicator of
protein
quantity and also potentially
as a result of that indicate any
deviations
so as he said and as he showed in the
graphs
osmolality along with uv 260 and 280 can
be used as
inputs for a very simple statistical
model to predict the protein
concentration for your maps
and although osmolality is not yet
available as an online measurement
advanced instruments does offer
osmometers that can provide
really simple accurate and fast
outline testing they come ready to fit
into your workflow
so no matter what your needs are again
as far as data
integrity and connectivity we can meet
those needs and definitely work with you
to get everything set up
in an efficient way
with that we just like to thank you so
much for your attention today
and on behalf of dr alois youngbauer
i'd like to invite you at this time
to ask any questions thank you so much
thank you dr youngbauer and dr wright
for your informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's go ahead and get started
okay our first question is
with respect to upstream cell culture
process
for monoclonal antibodies production
what ranges
of abnormality are appropriate for cell
viability
growth and for monoclonal antibodies
productivity
i think there is a a pretty
actually narrow range
of osmolality yeah uh i think this is
very well uh uh
documented uh in literature i think also
advanced instruments has um
application notes about this yeah
because at the higher
or lower osmolarity uh that's
uh in the range of 400 million small
you might actually
actually change the viability of the
cells here
and this puts on stress on the cells but
i think there are cells around which are
more
uh more resistant
or too high or low osmotic pressure than
others
maybe also christina you could comment
on this yeah
sure um yeah i i totally agree and i
would say
um of course it's going to depend on
what cells you're working with
um most of our customers are
typically if they're working with cho
cells um
reporting something around the 290
to 300 milli osmo per kilogram water
range
however we have definitely like you said
dr youngbauer we've seen a range
and it depends on the cell line it
depends on what your goals are
uh from your cell culture so um we're
happy to kind of work through that with
you if it's something that you're
interested in please
feel free to contact us
great thank you okay let's move on to
our next question
what um sorry what osmolality range
helps in clearing monoclonal antibodies
aggregates
in the purification process and at what
step
so uh uh should i ask this and answer
this question or
uh christina should go ahead uh i i i
say hello
yeah you can hear me yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh uh
actually um
usually you remove the uh aggregates uh
either in the intermediate purification
uh nowadays uh the
flow through chromatography is quite
popular for this purpose
yeah uh that because it's known
that for instance the aggregates uh bind
uh
a stronger to for instance cation
exchanger
compared to the monomers yeah so
uh but usually this process
is very sensitive to a sword
concentration yeah
so you would go actually to conditions
where you just actually pass through
the uh the exit monomers
and you bind the aggregates yeah
so this is actually a very
subtle process and needs a lot of fine
tuning
another more robust process exactly
hydrophobic
interaction chromatography for removal
of
monomer aggregates from monomers yeah
because here is the same the the the
aggregates
bind much stronger compared to the
monomer
yeah and so uh the monomer will be
eluted uh
uh uh actually uh
later
earlier compared actually to the
aggregate yeah
thank you how would this model apply to
capture chromatography
operation rather than flow through
[Music]
what do you mean
the mess of the osmolarity measurement i
did not completely understand the
question
so i think where would if your setup
involved
um rather than a flow-through process
um i think if you want a flow through or
a behind-the-loop process i think this
really depends
uh uh also on on the company on the
history
uh what i mentioned before uh maybe it
is
it's more difficult in a flow through
operation
to find robust conditions compared to a
bind
loot process
great thank you okay our next question
is if we want to try this modeling
method alongside purification
what is the best way to get started
so what is meant with the best way to
get started
if we do like a modeling or so yeah
uh uh uh for the for the modeling
actually if you really want to go into
this uh
a real-time uh uh release things
is uh um
actually uh
you have to to to actually set up
either a couple of training grants
or i think quite often is available
you have already repetitive runs
in your company uh
and then this would be great yeah
because you have already the uv data
and so on and you could try actually to
establish
a simple mathematical model and
and later on uh you can
actually include more and more uh
uh online and atlanta headline sensors
yeah and actually what we have had done
and we were mostly surprised that the
osmolality
we said as an headlight sensor which is
actually
works quite fast gave us
very promising results
and i think to thank you for that and
also i
i think to add on to that um if you're
interested or need any support um from
advanced instruments obviously
we have a team that that can respond to
whatever needs you have
um and dr youngbauer has been great as
far as kind of advising
on this model obviously so um
we're more than willing to help you get
started um
and make sure that you have you know the
equipment and understand
kind of the process to get all of that
started so that it's
nice and smooth and efficient for you
great thanks so much okay next question
is what is the difference between
upstream and downstream osmonality
during monoclonal antibody production
christina do you want to answer this
question or should i
answer um we could both
i i think so i'm not sure if the
question is specifically about
um the range but
maybe i think some of what you presented
earlier
dr young barracks sort of spoke to that
um
so if you want to start and then i can
definitely kind of add
if there's anything else
no i i i think uh in the
in the uh upstream processing uh
it is well established that uh
the the people uh actually
use a uh
actually a medium which is well balanced
uh regarding the osmolality
or small or osmolarity yeah so uh
that's that's uh actually uh
this is historically yeah uh
nowadays actually quite often uh
you can actually get more inside yeah
when you develop the process
for the cultivation when you have
actually
methods at hand where you can easily
measure the osmolality
yeah because if you are actually
upstream processing is not working
properly yeah
you would actually get a hypotonic
solution at at the very end because
maybe you actually titrate uh
your uh uh bioreactor
uh that the the broth the cells with
actually a base for instance and then
you add
more and more solutes and the osmolarity
increases
in downstream processing honestly except
as to say
accept the formulation development
osmolality has not been used
so far yeah so this is a completely
new area
and i think to your point earlier also
the
the focus maybe shifts right from
um yes the yeah from the
from the health of the cell and um you
know trying to make sure that
that you have productive cells you have
that great
yield coming out of your upstream
process and then in the downstream
um as we showed you just kind of looking
at
your buffers which are now interacting
with your drug substance and the
proteins it's a little bit
the focus kind of shifts on on where i
should be looking at osmology
i think where it's also very important
to use the osmolality testing or
a very convenient yeah because it's a
temperature independent what we
mentioned at the beginning
is with this inline dilution
yeah or the dilution a lot of companies
nowadays
they buy actually stock solutions for
their buffers
and then they dilute it and when you use
osmolality as a parameter
then it's much more accurate
compared to conductivity or
actually ph and ph
because at very high salt concentration
uh the conductivity concept conductivity
measurement
may fail you get failed means you get
inaccurate or you have to dilute
your stock solution to to measure the
accurate
conductivity without molality
you have a quality parameter because you
can measure this
stock solution without further dilution
great thanks so much okay now this next
question is a two-part question
says first off thank you for your
presentation i am working with
recombinant
proteins final formulation based on a280
a280 is in the region of 0.3
to 0.5 a u can osmolality provide
consistent and precise results uh
so in the final
uh uh uh i i think to measure the
osmolarity
yeah uh would definitely uh
help you yeah help you to
to add or to get
a a higher let's say
a more robust process for the final
uh formulation yeah
yeah now also
once you have like a free store and you
have
some uh uh precipitation
uh definitely you would actually see
this because
then uh quite often the protein
not the protein precipitates with other
solutes and so
yeah because then you see really
the change of the solution
properties after freestyle
great thank you okay your next question
is
how do you measure osmolality within a
cell
i i think uh
maybe currently uh uh there
is maybe there are some very
sophisticated physical methods around
but
it's not possible to measure the
osmolality
uh uh in a single in a in a single cell
in the cell itself
what you measure usually is the
osmolarity
of the pros yeah
so of the the the the
of the medium and not the osmolality in
the cell
because the osmolality in the cell and
the osmolality
in the medium would be different and
this
is the reason why you want to have
physiological conditions
in your cell culture or in your
bioreactor
because the cell needs
energy to maintain actually
uh the physiological condition within
the
within the cell yeah and if the
surrounding
is actually not physiological it takes a
lot of
energy to maintain these conditions
inside the cell either they have to pump
to pump out actually
a solute or to pump in water
now is it possible to modulate protein
aggregation within a cell using
osmolality
of the cell media
i think this is definitely i'm not
really a real expert in upstream
processing
but it has been shown that actually the
wrong
osmotic pressure in in a
in a cell catcher or in a catcher
may lead actually to protein aggregation
great now your next question is can
advanced instruments
3250 single step single sample
osmometer be used for usb network
or other options to download data
so um currently the 3250
we do not have those same uh
network connectivity options that we
offer with the
osmo tech and the osmo tech pro
um but certainly if you
um currently have a 3250 and have any
questions about
potentially switching to another
instrument or
need additional information on our
products
on the osmo tech line of instruments
please feel free to reach out to us and
we can certainly
work with you to find a solution if your
connectivity needs aren't currently
being met
great thank you that looks like we have
time for one more question
and this question says can you speak to
the potential savings
of implementing this model in downstream
processing
uh it's uh it's difficult to
to say that at the time at the the cost
savings yeah or
operational costs i think what we
mentioned before
implementing osmolality measurements
will be actually
again you will get more robust processes
and if of course if you have a more
robust process
this uh at the end would
actually also lead to to cost savings or
time savings
okay it looks like we just got one more
question in from the audience so let's
go ahead and ask this one before we
close
and it says are there chemicals known to
interact with osmolality measurement
i'm working with formulation buffers
that have polysorbate in them
and was wondering if that would have an
impact on the accuracy
of the measure i think this
is the beauty of the osmolality
that actually it measures
uh the amount of uh osmolytes
of these soft compounds in the
in the solution uh and
actually it captures if there are
interactions the osmolarity measurement
would capture this
yeah so uh uh it's the
it's it's then it's the number uh of
dissolved compounds for instance
if you would add a
cationic compound
into your formulation buffer and the
cationic
compound actually binds uh
some anions yeah then you would see this
uh when you measure the osmolality
yeah and if and if i can't add um this
is actually
i'm glad that we got this question it's
a question that we've gotten before
with especially more um viscous
uh either reagents or solutions or
whatever it is
um that's added to the different samples
we've gotten the question of whether
um you know freezing point depression is
an answer is a solution for obsolete
testing
um and we've certainly our technology
has proven to be pretty robust when it
comes to a lot of these samples
if it's something that you're interested
in testing out before
you know potentially making an
investment we do also
offer excuse me sample testing as well
um so please feel free to reach out to
us
um and also you know speaking of tween
we have some
previous samples that we've gotten
before with different concentrations
of things like polysorbates um 20 and
80. so
we can certainly um field your specific
questions
and just feel free to contact us we can
certainly work with you on that as well
and figuring out which instruments the
best for you
thank you again dr young bauer and dr
wright do you have any final comments
for our audience
i i don't think so um i do definitely
want to thank everyone that's attended
we certainly appreciate your time and
attention and look forward to
sharing more data and more a great
information with you in the future
okay now i also don't have any any
product comment i actually
also thank you for the questions because
i also
learn through these
questions thank you
thank you and before we go i'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and further questions as
well questions we did not have time for
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the email addresses you provide at
the time of registration
we would like to thank dr alice
youngbauer and dr
christina wright for their time today
and for their important research
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor advanced instruments for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now we hope to see you
again soon have a great day